vanessa warwick from property tribes
guys be warned okay
i've put content about vanessa up a
couple times she has
a really good skill of being able to
remove things
from the internet i put this video up
before and it just disappeared
she had it banned she had it removed she
says it's the police
is it really the police she talks about
me even she says that there's an ongoing
police investigation about between me
and her
if there is i am not aware of it
anything you hear from vanessa
about anybody make sure you always ask
for proof because she just
makes things up tears people down if you
didn't see the video
you're going to see it now the one that
she obviously doesn't want you to see
this because she got this removed from
youtube
and if you did see the video comment and
let me know that you saw it and watch it
again i usually like to focus on the
good
however in this video i need to warn you
of a lady
she is venomous she is incorrect
when talking about property nearly all
of the time and
she is somewhere that's desperate to see
people fail her name is vanessa warwick
and vanessa warrick i'm going to go
through a whole bunch of points about
vanessa
she talks about property investing a lot
that she's a failed
property investor herself she set up a
training company
and tried to teach and was going around
doing events and failed miserably
she was exposed in the media and now she
has a
website where she tells other people how
not to invest in property
and always talks utter tripe
and in this video i felt like for the
greater good of the property community
i needed to explain point by point by
point
how she is misleading people and how she
is stopping people be successful as a
property investor
and as she is ultimately full of
absolute crap that
even if you could get into a property um
without a deposit which i don't believe
you can
you've got all your stamp duty your
acquisition costs your legal costs
part of my mission is to help people
enable people how to get into property
when they're starting with very little
money now vanessa says that you can't do
that
and she tries to disprove all of the
strategies that i teach
specifically things like lease option
agreements she says she says that lease
option agreements
don't work on residential properties
this is just absolute out and out
incorrect and wrong
she also says i doubt samuel has ever
done any talking about lease option
agreements i
again this is just complete and utter
nonsense what she's trying to do is
she's trying to make people that are
beginning to think creatively around
property
that are looking at alternative
strategies to finance their deals and
she's just saying
it doesn't work try telling that to ian
patterson
who built up he's one of my students and
he built up a large portfolio of lease
option agreements
i bought hmo straight after that crash
course in stoke
yeah um and then i realized my strategy
was probably this options was better for
me so yeah involved that big chunk of
cash
up front yeah um and i found that i
could do that easy
and get invented straight away and yeah
how many properties have you got now
these options actually
fall together and then it enabled him to
leave his job he was so successful it
may be the newspapers
what he'd done with lease option
agreements and she's saying it doesn't
work for residential properties
it does try to send that to sam hawking
and co the solicitor
that day in day out does purchase lease
option agreements on
residential property it's just
completely and
utterly wrong and to say i haven't done
any
i mean i've been doing lease option
agreements for many many years not only
have i secured these option agreements
but i've also gone right through to the
very end after the five
six seven years and then bought them
i've been doing it for years
i've been vlogging it on my channel it's
just
beyond me how she could come up with
something that is so moronic
and then to try and put you off doing
these option agreements
she found a guy in australia who
was apparently well known for lease
option agreements that had some problems
and got fined
i don't know anything about it but it
apparently wasn't a good guy
and she then published and said that was
the guy
who was samuel's mentor that got him
into lease option agreements i'm like
was it i've never even heard of the guy
like
it is absolute i don't even remember the
person's name that she was talking about
but she said that he was my mentor i'm
like
no proof no facts why would she say
that he was my mentor it baffles me and
then she was the same person
that got alan sugar's pr agency to say
he didn't give me any business advice
even when he did and i've obviously
since i've proven that
she was the person behind that and she
brags about it so she thinks that
lord sugar didn't mentor me even when he
did
but this guy from australia did mentor
me even when he didn't
the truth is she'll just make whatever
up to try and make me look bad
and to try and stop you being successful
in property
she doesn't just attack property
investors she doesn't just attack
me and my company she also attacks the
whole industry
she attacks all the strategies that are
helpful to people that are starting out
from scratch and
one time she was getting harassed online
people were saying bad things about her
and she got really really upset
and she actually contacted me and she
said samuel i think that some of your
students are behind this
i said okay and she phoned me up
repeatedly caught me again and again i'm
like
why is vanessa calling me again and
again over face call
um on a sunday night at like 11 30. so i
answered
and she was saying to me can you please
get them to stop get them to stop i said
vanessa
i can't control my fans i had a little
conversation with her where she said to
me
you know the things they said about
youtube it was nothing personal i just
disagree slightly with some of the
things that you teach i was like that's
cool i had a nice conversation and then
shortly after she said that i was a
vulture
i bumped into her a property conference
i said hey
she looked like the world could have
swore up she almost cowered like a
little puppy dog
but then goes and says that i've lied
300 times
name one vanessa you are just completely
full of crap
so why does she do this why does she say
all this nonsense online
why does she harass me and then say i
harass her
why does she contact my family members
contact my pastor
to try and get me kicked out of my
church of which by the way he thought
was very very silly
well i don't know exactly why but let's
take a little look down memory lane and
have a look at vanessa's back story
because if you want to know where
someone's coming from like if you want
to know where i'm coming from as a
person
if you take a look at my backstory over
the last you know 15 years you'll be
able to think oh that makes sense i can
see why now he does youtube videos every
day i can see why now he has a training
company i can see why he does this
because you can see my backstory and if
you want to see my backstory check it
out on youtube
but if you want to see vanessa's
backstory it's very difficult because
she hides her backstory she deletes
things she forces things to be taken
offline
because she is a failed property
investor
she has zero success if you go on the
the co
you might think is that true is that
fair the way that she judges if a
company is successful
she just goes on to company's house she
goes on due diligence you do that on her
you'll see no properties and you'll see
a net worth of around about a thousand
pounds
it's literally embarrassingly empty she
is so
broke okay if you do your due diligence
on her to claim that she's an expert to
claim that she's a
successful property investor i actually
find it really really embarrassing
i mean you can look at me on company's
house and you can see and i know
i own a lot of my properties outside of
companies and i've talked about that but
you can see that i've made
millions of pounds through my companies
you can see that i own property you can
see that i own a castle you can see that
but with her what does she own
she doesn't own anything she's broke the
only
home that we can find that she actually
owns is her own house that she lives in
but even her own house that she lives in
it's a very unimpressive house
and she lives there with her husband and
she has two lodges living with her to
help pay the mortgage
so the fact that she's got the audacity
where anyone goes on property tribes and
says
tries to debate her or tries to argue
with her and what does she do
when you try and argue with her she just
says i'm not going to talk to you until
you can prove your net worth
and prove your success but it's like
well what's your success
you know when someone went on there and
asked about me she was going well look
at these companies look at this company
it's like
but look at your company so not only is
she a fraud and a failure
but she's the ultimate hypocrite i have
first-hand experience of seeing that
some of these checks on due diligence
and these these
these company sites i have first-hand
experience of seeing that sometimes
they're not correct
sometimes they can't find properties
they can't find wealth but that's what
she uses to check people's wealth
that's what she uses to check people's
success so by her own standards of doing
due diligence
she is a complete failure now maybe you
think i'm being harsh maybe you think i
should cut her a little bit of slack
but the thing is i have no problem with
people failing in property
that's what happens if you don't get
trained properly and if you're a bit
unlucky and if things go on you can fail
in property and she's failed very badly
in property
that's not a problem i don't have an
issue with that but what really irks me
is when people fail in property very
badly fail
and then go on to position himself as an
expert
and she doesn't do this anymore because
it also failed
but she started training people and the
presentation that i give
is how to source manage and
market a uk holiday let to achieve
above average occupancy so i hope you'll
come and join me at one of the events
and i look forward to seeing you there i
can't believe
that after her lack of success in
property she had the audacity to start
teaching people about property and i've
heard some horror stories i won't go
into all of them but i've heard stories
of people that went and listened to her
training
and she didn't know what she was talking
about she talks about holiday let's but
then
when asked if she had holiday let she
didn't even know that you needed a
different type of mortgage
to rent out a property on a holiday
let's see it's like okay so have you got
holiday let's but you're renting them
out illegally or have you not and you
were complete and utter
fraud i mean which which one is it it's
embarrassing
and now she writes countless stories
about me
and tries to get them off into the media
tries to get them in print
if i make the media and it's good she
goes crazy and
trolls it it it's it's like why does she
do that
is it because she was exposed in the
media some years ago
this is money wrote a very damning story
about vanessa i mean i've got it right
here
they said so driven by social
embarrassment i signed up for the free
inside
track seminar to find out how the whole
thing works the two and a half hour
seminar was run by
vanessa vanessa has been on inside track
weekend herself and told us
at frequent intervals that she has made
a fortune
since had you vanessa had you made a
fortune
i don't think you had she is very good
you can be a millionaire in three years
or less she says
it's embarrassing i mean it's not if
you're a millionaire and you say that
and your and your mission is to help
people and look i became a millionaire
here's what i did then it's no problem
but i think the reason that
this this story got in this is money
was because it was embarrassing and what
happened to inside track
inside track went bust went into
liquidation
so now it's no wonder that she's trying
to not only stop people from succeeding
in property because she failed so
miserably
but now it makes her blood boil seeing
other people succeeding as property
trainers
i wouldn't even talk about her if she
wasn't so determined
to misinform people like you and tell
you things like these options don't work
and this doesn't work
and also she didn't talk about me
constantly i mean look at this
samuel leads 116 times
and these are all the things like samuel
leaves samuel leeds
like falsifying charity deeds what
christian study false claims this is big
thing about how i didn't really go to
bible college i did go to bible college
i spent three years there
and how many times is she gonna
caught photoshopping evidence caught
photoshopping let's have a look at this
there we go there's her one property
trainer
john howard she says that he's the only
property trainer in the world
that she could possibly recommend and it
just so happens that he's one of her
sponsors
okay um but i have a design degree this
is on property tribes i have a design
degree and use adobe shop
i specialize in this i've left off my
expertise to show the tax bill shown in
san luis video is a doctor photo
so apparently this is doctored and this
is what i put up to show that i'd paid
like hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of pounds in tax
over the last year it's not doctored
it's
i mean if she'd meet me i could show her
my actual banks i could show my blog
into my actual bank it's just
this is just nonsense and what does
vanessa have to say
um i guess samuel didn't stop to think
that someone could pause the video
and look at the screenshot properly i
mean really
really and and there's so many samuel
leeds
simon zushi claims samuel leaves lied
and then she'll put something out
not only did samuel lie about his
testimony about sugar it now seems he
lied about his testimony from simon
zushi
and and then i put the evidence out and
show that actually
i wasn't and then what and then you
can't comment on the thread anymore but
you can't you can't comment this thread
is now frozen
it's just so unethical and so wrong the
way that she does things
and look recommend it it's all bad news
it's all like rich greenland is in
trouble and
refusing to refund bankruptcy this guru
that
it's just really quite depressing
i heard of him and she's talking about
me now samuel lee the landlord's in
distress
um a quick look on julian due diligence
reveals the following
does not reveal any evidence of success
or wealth other than his own claims
really you can't find any you can't find
any success
of mine other than my own claims and how
does she do that she does that by just
having a look on company's house
and there we go so she's just shown one
of my companies
it's got minus 2.6 fine one of my
companies
i sold that company by the way and it
was actually behind because company's
house wasn't
it takes 18 months for companies has to
register but okay what am i go go find
but i mean you can you can you can look
on company's house but this is company's
house
and look you can see everything's all
public and yes whilst i do have my
properties in my personal name pretty
much
look at this this is just 2019
investment properties 1.3 million
pounds total equity 2 million pounds
this this is where you can see on
company's house about me what about what
about vanessa
well let's have a look i don't think it
will be quite so nice
this is vanessa warwick who is twice my
age
exactly okay um
so she got one company all right fine
and that one company is a consultancy
company
okay let's have a look how it's doing
that uh maybe he invests in property
maybe he's doing really well
uh if we go filing history we'll check
the accounts
and let's see how well our company's
doing these are her most
recent accounts of her one and only
company
okay so they're unaudited no problem no
problem that's okay it's okay
let's see
[Music]
so she made 1761 pounds
that was how much she made the whole of
last year
compared to my over 2 million so set in
stone consultancy sucks we know that
but let's see her husband nick tad let's
see what his companies are doing
okay property tribes where all the money
is so filing history
account
okay
ah that's where the money is
so that's how they make their living
all right property tribes 175 grand not
a bad salary for talking nonsense about
people
i mean that's where the money's at
hasn't it got investment companies
though does he have does he have
investment companies well let's find out
so uh prop nick tad
there he is nicholas william tadd so
he's only got three companies he's got
property tribes the bigger one
he's got rent buddy limited
honestly that sounds very wrong rent
buddy is that okay fine
um sandstone consultancy and that's it
well we know setting stone consultancy
is terrible
rent buddy limited what even is rent
bully limited um
other information technology service
activities so that's not even property
so where where like where where is the
property
so that and this is the thing they're
just talking about property on property
tribes
about all this horrible stuff getting
everybody clicking making
zero money in property some people say
you can get all the information you want
for free
you get all the information online for
free no you just read it on here
and then and then rent to rent let's see
the kind of stuff they talk about what
they're gonna say about rent to rent
fabulous strategy probably about how bad
it is
arrears not getting rent paid
so this this this whole hub in my
opinion just sucks
and the people that run it are broke
with no money
a little bit of money from property
tribes not from training
that failed not from investing in
property
that failed no evidence of success just
by
talking about people and what's her
response to me what's her response to me
saying hey let's meet let's talk of
course she doesn't want to talk to me
because i just expose her but what she
says is she says samuel's harassing me
he harassed me the police were involved
no she was harassed by other people i
don't know she was
harassed by she even says it here she
says samuel
was harassing me to get my husband to
delete the threads about him
started by other people on property
tribes i didn't harass her
i didn't do anything unethical i didn't
try and bully her i just said
that it's incorrect she was bullying me
using my name for clickbait i just said
hey
you know i want you to delete those
threads they're not they're not correct
it's not right that's all i said
and then she goes and starts making a
big song announced about how harassed
her
i only phoned her up once i phoned her
up and i said hey you've been saying a
lot of stuff about me i want to chat she
didn't even let me finish she was
she was just like bum putting the phone
down on me absolute character she's a
fraud
a failure and a coward and vanessa if
i'm wrong
if all of these facts and this hard
evidence is not true then talk to me and
tell me but i know you won't because
what vanessa
what she does is she just plays the
victim oh i'm being bullied i'm being
harassed
isn't it a shame isn't hard no no you
wrote about me
online dozens and dozens of times for
four
years you contacted my family my pastor
and all i'm doing is i'm just responding
because i need to talk about facts as
well
i go by the facts you don't go by the
facts you don't go by the facts you're
going to play on emotion now
i'm so upset this is so why is so upset
why you've been talking about it for
four years and if you think i'm being
harsh vanessa i know you're watching
this
you think what i'm saying is wrong then
i'd be very happy
for us to meet up and have a discussion
and we can put it out there live but of
course you don't want that to happen
because you know that i'm right and the
truth really really hurts
when you are a fraud of failure and
probably a witch
and if i'm wrong i'm very happy to be
proved wrong maybe vanessa's
secretly a multi-millionaire and she has
it in offshore accounts and different
contracts
i don't know but anyway if you like this
video
smash the like button what do you think
of vanessa is vanessa a fraud or is that
a bit harsh is she a fake
is she a phony uh is she broke
as it looks like she is or is she
actually a secret millionaire superhero
i don't know comment your thoughts
um is she a witch because she always
bashes my religion as well she was
that's another thing i've noticed
she called me no it's nick her husband
call me a self-centered self-worshiping
christian
imagine imagine if you said that about
muslims imagine if there was a muslim
and you were like he's just he's a
self-worth being a muslim it's like
what's that got to do with anything
you know she hates me she hates my
success she hates your success
she hates my religion uh vanessa come on
grow up
grow up or come and have a conversation
be a big girl anyway folks
thanks for watching i will see you next
time i'm gonna be doing some videos real
soon about how
doable lease option agreements are on
residential property about rent to
rent about how you can get started with
very little money
and how you can become very successful
and earn more than 1
700 pounds a year peace out thanks so
much
i later found out the reason she was
able to get this youtube video removed
was because i actually played a snippet
of me ringing her and being really
friendly and saying hey let's look can
we talk
and she whacks the phone on me because i
don't want to talk really rude
okay so i put that in the last video and
because of that
i didn't have the copyright to do it she
managed to get the video taken down
beware of vanessa she did exactly what
we predicted as well
my brother and business partner alistair
did a podcast and they said last time i
played the video they said what
vanessa's going to do she's going to
play the victim
she's going to say i'm being bullied
she's going to she's going to start
throwing
slinging stuff at samuel with no
evidence but the thing is
if you see her doing that just ask her
the simple questions all you need to ask
vanessa was this
why did you say that rick otton was
samuel's mentor can you please provide
proof no proof why did you say that
lease option agreements don't work can
you provide
provide proof no proof why do you judge
people
based on their due diligence on
companies house but when you do that for
you
there's no evidence of any success in
fact vanessa what evidence of success do
you have
that you've been successful in property
no evidence no success
no proof these are the types of
questions that you're very simply to ask
her
what evidence minister do you have that
samuel did something wrong
according to the police and he was you
know accused because i say so i did go
to the police station but
they had nothing on me at all so for you
to go around saying that making out i'm
some kind of a criminal
what evidence do you have no why won't
you debate samuel because i want to be
in the same room as him because of the
made-up police investigation let's just
have a zoom call then
none no evidence so ask these very very
simple questions
and she won't be able to answer them
ever and also ask her why do you keep
silencing people and removing people's
videos removing people's stuff
but then talk about as if you're open
and you try and you know get to the
bottom of the truth
all lies and that's why she won't meet
me anyway guys
i'll see you next time where i'll be
teaching more about property and
hopefully we'll be on some more positive
notes peace out